Speaker 1: Arguably the biggest political
question right now in Republican world is
will the Trump people abandon Trump once and
for all because of the FBI search warrant
served at Mar a Lago?
There's the Trump legality question, of course,
which is, is he going to get charged?
Is he going to jail?
Whatever?
Will he be eligible to run in 2024?
But then there's the would people vote for
him?
And one of the things that we learned is that
these MAGA people, many of whom were never
involved in politics, pre-Trump, may or may
not remain involved in politics.
Once Trump is no longer the person involved
in politics and, you know, we maybe have one
more election cycle where where Trump will
be involved.
And so it was with great interest that I awaited
seeing some of exactly these interviews and
clips that we're going to play for you today,
which is your Random magazine reacting to
the FBI search warrant.
And unfortunately, it's scary and it's insane.
This is not merely disaster porn, although
it is.
It's also about is there anything for which
they would abandon Donald Trump?
Now, there's been the infamous.
I could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue and
people would still vote for me.
And that may be the case.
And compared to that, this seems relatively
benign in some sense.
So let's go right into some of these clips.
Here's one guy saying this is another bunch
of rigger Morse, rigger Morse.
Speaker 5: All of our jealousy is beyond us.
Speaker 2: Roberts shared the same sentiment.
Speaker 5: Have you seen the documents?
To prove it or reasonable doubt that these
are deaths is a true statement or is another
political point to regret more to make him
look even worse?
Speaker 1: Now, aside from the fact that rigor
mortis is not a word, maybe he meant rigamarole.
Maybe he went some kind of rigor mortis.
Morse code, the sort of morse code of a dying
political dynasty.
I don't know.
I'm just kidding.
I don't know what this guy is talking about,
but there is a level of skepticism that these
folks apply to any criticism of their beloved
Orange leader that they don't apply elsewhere.
Speaker 2: Oh, no.
Speaker 1: And he can say anything and they
will defend him.
And indeed, that seems to be the case here.
Fox News, to their credit, they went down
to Mar a Lago and they interviewed protesters
and people who were out rallying for Trump
and whatever else.
And it's it's really scary.
It's quite frankly, it's we have a crisis
of critical thinking in this country.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: What is your view on the FBI and
why they decided to raid the former president's
property?
Speaker 3: I think they're just a mafia.
You know, been ordered by Ray.
Speaker 1: And yeah, it's a mafia ordered
by Ray.
Ray being the FBI director who was chosen
by Donald Trump and who Donald Trump expressed
unending confidence in.
That's the guy who's running the mafia.
Speaker 3: Hmm.
I Ray.
And after this man.
Speaker 4: Our ex president, for so long,
they.
They're trying to find any kind of dirt they
can pull up on him.
This is insane.
I never see this happening in United States.
Biden has to go to jail.
John Kerry is the one that has to go and get
it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Hunter.
Go and get Hunter.
Now, what does Hunter have that the FBI would
need to recover via a search warrant?
I'm not aware of anything whatsoever.
And so there's a combination here of unending
devotion to the cult leader.
There is.
What about ism?
And we've seen the whataboutism has been heavy.
What about Hillary Clinton?
Well, Benghazi was investigated.
The email stuff was investigated.
We know exactly why she wasn't charged with
Benghazi.
She sat under oath and testified for 8 hours.
There were 11 investigations.
I believe the number is these things are completely
and totally different.
There is no similarity.
Hunter Biden, what on earth is Hunter Biden
have to do with any of this?
And then, of course, they talk about Obama.
What?
I don't.
OBAMA What?
Obama Great, they say, but they can't even
explain what that is.
One more of these clips.
This is also Fox News speaking to more people
about the search for him.
And everybody's as confused as you can imagine.
Speaker 2: And that's basically I mean, this
has been going on now for over six years.
Ever since he came down the escalator.
They've been after him.
Speaker 1: By the way, this entire down the
escalator.
Trump has started using it as a sort of nostalgic
phrase.
From the moment I came down the escalator
with our beautiful first lady, they've been
going after me.
That's the thing.
Now, his followers, his sycophantic followers
have started to repeat the whole down the
escalator what the full story would be.
Ever since Trump came down the escalator and
suggested most Mexicans coming over to the
U.S. are murderers and rapists, it's been
X, Y, Z.
They'll never mention that extra little part.
Speaker 2: Yesterday was the ultimate.
We've never seen anything like that.
My life.
Speaker 3: I believe that they're trying to
make it so he cannot run.
I think they're trying to attack the American
people and they're trying to go after the
person who put us first and put our American
godly values first that.
Speaker 1: We know what's funny about that?
Put us first and put godly values first.
Let's deal with them one by one terms of Godly
first.
Trump's not religious.
Trump has never been religious.
Trump doesn't have any spiritual beliefs.
It was all a sham, just like his supposedly
anti-abortion stance.
This was all contrived and fabricated in order
to justify himself as a candidate for the
Republican nomination, because the Democratic
primary electorate would never have fallen
for Trump in the first place.
Bottom line, Trump's not religious.
And you can look at what's your favorite Bible
verse?
Well, that's very personal.
And when he talked about two Corinthians as
if they walk into a bar all it he's not religious
but these folks think this is a godly man.
But more importantly, he put us first.
And there's almost a tinge of sadness with
that.
And the reason I say sadness is these people
are so duped.
Trump has spent his entire life as a privileged,
rich kid from Queens who grew up in Manhattan
or from Manhattan?
Who grew up in Queens, whatever.
Queens.
Manhattan.
He's been trying to insulate himself from
these folks his entire life, the people that
donated the money to him, the people that
put him in the White House.
These aren't people that he actually likes.
And as we've seen, he only even tolerates
them to the extent that they're useful to
him, either financially or more recently in
his political career when they're useful politically,
but they've been duped.
They've fallen for it.
It's really something else.
Speaker 3: Godly values first.
That's why I believe they're going after him
to intimidate us as Americans.
Speaker 1: Okay.
In all seriousness, I don't know that even
this is enough for the maggots to bail.
It seems that the weekend saw kind of like
a little bit shakier support.
And I had the sense come Monday, come today,
they'll be united.
They'll either be united behind Trump or united
in abandoning Trump.
It's still not clear that it's all kind of
shaken out, but they have a perfect way to
cut ties with him, they could even say and
try to maintain some credibility.
We loved his platform in 2016.
He did good things in 2016.
We voted for him in 2020.
We even think he won in 2020.
Repeat the big lie.
But at this point he has become politically
toxic and the Republican Party needs to go
in a different direction.
They don't even really have to criticize him.
They have an off ramp.
It doesn't seem as though the maggots are
actually willing and ready.
I'm seeing Hunter this, Hillary that, Obama
this and the other thing.
But Trump's godly and he's great and all this
different stuff to their own to their own
detriment at this point in time.